hi welcome to another episode of get
close i am your co-host gio and i'm bart
and today is a good good day why guys i
get to spend some cuny time staring at
your crotch and just your crotch alone
we don't have another guest we have a
little bear friend back hi mr bear i
hope you've been well looking uh looking
soft and cuny as ever
um today i want to talk about something
that i constantly get dms about i'm sure
you don't know
what
i don't know do you check your dms nah
okay cool um but i do and i like to
engage with my uh
you know with people that follow me and
stuff
and a lot of the questions that i get
are from first time parents and they
always ask me like what should i expect
what should i be doing what should i be
prepping for
um
help
and i want to talk about that today i
feel like um
we're very wingy
okay i don't know about we but i'm a
very winged type of person and i feel
like when i have a grasp of things i
think that might be the same concept
that you call abc xyz i think when i
understand my abcs and the xyz of things
then i feel like i'm pretty i can wing
it and i can figure it out like i could
figure out the middle section on my own
and it when it came to having taika i
definitely did do a lot of research and
i had like the abs that was following
all the stages of the development when
he was
in my little tummy tums
and um i read books
i read like the psychology that i would
you know the different
psychology that i was going to get into
when being pregnant when giving birth
when having the kids i did do research
but i felt like i did the abc xyz method
where i'm like let me just know the both
both of the extremes and then i'll just
kind of like
learn as i go um so i think we did good
um we were fortunate enough that my mom
stayed with us for the first couple of
years so like i got really hands-on
training when it came to like
simple things like how to swaddle in a
more comfortable way or how to have them
lay down when like i needed to go wash
dishes or whatever like these are all
things that i don't think a book can
really teach you
[Laughter]
awesome thanks for the [ __ ]
conversation this is great i'm just
listening um so i think it's really cool
to just share whatever insight we have
if we could remember any right because
we
hopefully we can enter this phase
again this year because we are going to
be trying or we started trying for baby
number two
wild to say that out loud but super
excited for that and um yeah it's
interesting what the brain does too
cause like
i'll have new moms so tiger's four i
have new moms ask me because they just
gave birth like hey did your body go
through this did this happen i'm like
i don't remember do you have any of that
you don't remember my hips did get wider
yeah you son of a [ __ ] you know what i
mean um
like what i remember yeah like are there
things where you're like oh my god that
was already so long ago i don't i can't
recall there's a lot of it that's like
that i think for me if i were to give a
few tips is um
you know when they say like
go to your school orientation when you
go to like the brand new school
um because one i'll show you where
everything is at yeah
two you'll
walk to all the classes you're going to
be at so that the day of
when there's full traffic on campus yeah
you're not panicking
you can kind of gauge okay i can grab a
snack between this class and that class
this is when i'll eat my lunch you kind
of get a good feel for the time and the
space that you're gonna need to do
things
um i think that is super important
especially when it comes to having a kid
so before having a kid
think about like the the schedule that
you think it's going to be
and actually live it
how did how did we do that
so i don't think we even knew what the
[ __ ] was about like what we were
entering
um
i think for
me at least
the familiarity part of it the part that
kicks me back is boot camp
uh in boot camp we have this thing
called fire watcher in the military of
the scene called firewatch where you
randomly wake up in the middle of night
sometimes be hour or two hours and it's
every single day
you know so like
the last level of preparedness is what
you're going to fall back on to right so
when
like taika would like cry at night and
it was either your time to feed my time
to feed or whatever that's where i
resort back only my time to feed i was
breastfeeding but i was but i would
support you you did right and then when
he was off your titties and he's on
formula i'm feeding him with formula and
you're sleeping now yeah so like i would
wake up and i'm like okay cool this is
the last and then i'd be able to slowly
kind of prepare and understand
the non-negotiable is by eight o'clock
we need to start wrapping [ __ ] up
because we need to be in bed by nine you
know like i start to like understand
um
what kind of demands it will have
because the first six months
is [ __ ] rough right you're not
sleeping
and especially for the mom because the
baby wants booby milk so
the mom is gonna be woken up two three
times a night and if the mom still has a
job that's super rough if the mom can
have like three months of maternity
leave that'd be awesome
but you know you just never know these
things and then
also coming home from work
people might be used to coming home from
work kicking their feet up you know
watching the game
but now you have someone that's crying
that needs interaction
and so like understanding that you know
and then
also understanding that now you have
something that is fully dependent on you
so you need to be there
all the time
and
i think a couple things that helped us
was first having a dog like a dog is
kind of like that
right you got to walk the dog in the
morning you got to walk the dog at night
that like if you don't interact the dog
gets sad you're like scratch at the door
come on come play with me so you kind of
understand it a little bit i think
that's a good baby stepper
but when it comes to
um
being with the kid i think being able to
kind of block out the schedule
and live that schedule even for a month
would be tremendously helpful yeah yeah
like even practice waking up in the
middle of the night
for no reason
walking around for 30 minutes okay i
understand what that's gonna be like
and then um like let's say
coming home from work
and then usually you're used to just
hanging up your back
maybe have one hour of an intense time
with your dog or one hour of intense
time with your significant other going
to the park
like being intentional and understanding
how that's gonna feel
then when the kid comes because if you
don't do any of these things that's when
i've seen a lot of parents get straight
up obliterated yeah especially when both
parents are working yeah when it's one
parent is able to stay at home they take
up like the most of that work
obliteration on their own yeah but even
that's tough you know because then if
the other parent is just kind of like
well that's your job i'm gonna just kick
you here
then you don't feel like a team and
that's when the relationship kind of
gets
uh
hurt a little bit too yeah dang so you
just went through a lot um
just now and i do want to break it down
a little bit more i do want to give a
mom like a female perspective and then a
male perspective because i don't really
know what you went through um a lot of
the tips that you just said are spot on
and i agree with everything that you're
saying
but i want to take it back a little bit
and
just start with finding out you're
pregnant
right so for me i wasn't really around a
lot of pregnant women or a lot of like
within our circle i was the first person
to get
pregnant um
but like that remembered it um
yeah i just didn't i didn't feel like i
had like the the support system around
me to really like explain it so i
started seeking out different friends
that uh already had kids and stuff and
and that i like admired the way they
were raising their kids so remember like
we would meet with different couples
that had kids already and these were
like older couples yeah and um you know
people that we respected and that we
looked up to their parenting style so
uh
i think mark bell was one of those
people yeah that we looked at and um
and like he was giving us pointers on
like what to expect
and that was really helpful but no one
really prepares you for what you're
about to embark
as a woman so i remember my first
trimester i found out i was pregnant
super excited um
prior to even becoming pregnant as soon
as we had that conversation of the green
light to start busting all sorts of nuts
and like uh having me what is that
called um uh
marinate in your [ __ ] sauces yeah
like i i did the pillow under the butt
method and like elevated my ass and
it depends on who you ask studies show
that like that doesn't really help but
then i mean who seemed like it helped
for us because it was like less than a
month we were like
and it worked no it wasn't less than a
month it was for sure like a month maybe
even two months
that it took us because yeah i remember
every time i got my period i got really
sad because i'm like oh i remember it
only happened like once okay well it was
a couple of months and um so i did that
to begin with
but even before doing that um
we knew we wanted to have kids so like
luckily for both of us we're very
responsible people we don't consume
alcohol we don't consume
drugs or whatever or if we ever did then
we knew that it needed to stop at a
certain point like we had experimented
with like ecstasy and we did [ __ ] like
that but as soon as the kid conversation
got really serious and the green light
happened then we stopped all of that the
the workouts became more intentional
like i started like squatting more than
ever just because you know my
pediatrician on my pediatrician uh um my
gynecologist was like keep doing that
keep training it's going to help you
during labor he was very he was a big
advocate of of me strength training
especially in the squat position because
it was like you know your body changes
the hips get wider
um the bones uh what happens um
it's thinner stronger not thinner but
like they just start like expanding a
little bit more because your body's
adjusting to deliver this child yeah so
yeah he was a huge advocate of stuff
like that and um i liked it i started
taking prenatals i did my research on
that and i started looking at you know i
started comparing things so i was
already on prenatals
and what else did we do i was drinking
more like i was i cut out all my sugars
like i knew that
um i have a big [ __ ] candy addiction
but as soon as the green light happened
i'm like [ __ ] i'm cutting all that [ __ ]
out like i'm not gonna give any of this
nasty [ __ ] to my kids i'll give it to
myself but not to my kid that's so
responsible of you yeah just seeing you
as a mom i thought was like so cool
because i was like oh man like i know
how much you like candy
and like
and we were so caffeine independent too
you know because we're because we're
like working so hard yeah and then
seeing you go mom time this body is no
longer mine it's for my kid boom no
candy no caffeine smoothie uh at that
like spot in downtown l.a every single
morning and i'm like wow that was a
crazy night and day difference yeah well
i mean i just feel like that's literally
what's happening you know you're you're
creating this house for your child so
why wouldn't you want to give it the
most premium
things well a lot of people
they still want to hold on to
the ownership of their own body yeah and
i know this is going to hurt some
people's feelings but you got to [ __ ]
stop doing that [ __ ] yeah like it's not
about you at this point yeah if it's
still about you then don't have a kid
that's true because if you're entering
it
with like oh but this is me this is who
i am [ __ ] off like
you you're not ready to have a kid if
you don't know how to let go and
sacrifice yeah for your offspring for
one small thing too and it's such a
short period of time nine months really
like in the span of your life and your
child's life you can't give up [ __ ]
nine months of some [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
don't be a parent true you know like um
i
you can give me all the excuses or all
the reasons why
you need this this and that whatever
yeah that to me tells me you're not
you're not ready you're not ready dude
um
like you should be you should be
saying hey it's not about me anymore the
dad should be doing the exact same [ __ ]
the dad shouldn't be consuming some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] if you know you want to
have a kid your sperm's also carrying a
lot of these things yeah there's uh
studies that show
that even with weed it taints the semen
and it carries over when like the
fertilization happens yeah so i think on
my end i was trying to clean things up
which is so ironic because you know the
whole dad bought i never got because i
was like trying to clean my sperm up
yeah and so
i was
getting my workouts in really good yeah
eating as healthy as you were yeah so as
you were getting bigger i was actually
getting leaner yeah and i kind of felt
bad too because i was like oh [ __ ] i'm
not getting the typical dad bot i'm
actually getting leaner and leaner yeah
i didn't care
i didn't feel like
i didn't feel bad because i was like
well it's not it's not for me right now
yeah like this this
i'm not supposed to be [ __ ] fit and
hot yeah yeah like cool if you're
everyone's body
carries a pregnancy differently so if
you are still fit and hot cool but if
you're i don't even say unfit and unhot
because that's not the opposite but if
you just don't feel fit and hot that's
fine that's what's supposed to [ __ ]
happen like that's why you don't see
pregnant women [ __ ] running the
olympics because it's just that's not
what you're supposed to be doing yeah
and all without and with all the studies
of epigenetics yeah where you pass on
the genes that you are expressing at
that time
that was so important to me you know
like there's like all those studies that
show when they took like semen from uh
dudes that are overweight and they do
like longitudinal studies
those kids end up having um more prone
to diabetic or diabetes
more prone to being overweight symptoms
for adhd and all that because they're
passing on the quote-unquote unhealthier
gene when the same exact father or
biological father or creature even
gets in shape
gets their cardiovascular cleanse up
their diet
their next generation of offspring with
the same sperm same mom in a
longitudinal study
those kids aren't prone to diabetes
anymore are prone to being overweight so
it's like the same exact person with
their sperm because that's the state
that you're in
those are the genes that you're passing
on so it was so important for me
to try to pass on like the best genes
possible yeah
um no and i love that it got to the
point too for me too where i wanted even
my state of mind to be really healthy
yeah because i didn't want i didn't want
to pass on even like
super sad genes
of course this is obviously me being
super extreme
and it's inevitable because i always
talk about the [ __ ] human experience
we're supposed to feel all these
emotions abso [ __ ] lootly but i just
made sure that i was laughing more and i
was like trying to hold on to things
less and not trying to take things
personally and just just being in a
blissful state as much as i could
control being in a blissful state just
because i wanted my kids to feel
comfortable the whole time you know
um so before we even got married we were
very much i mean married uh pregnant we
were very much aware
of like what this instrument needed to
like be polished and tuned up and [ __ ]
before
um before actually having a kid but even
prior to that it's not like you're gonna
be able to do it a month before you have
a kid like this is just a lot of life
decisions that we've made to just be
healthy people in general
so it made it really easy to switch to
that but
i mean you know i always knew i wanted
to have kids i think you always knew you
wanted to have kids um and one of the
things i loved about you when i got with
you was that you wanted to be fit and
capable so that you can pass on a lot of
skills obviously but that you can keep
up with your kids when they're like
[ __ ] around and playing you know
um that's my favorite thing when i go to
the park yeah and there's usually only
me and maybe one other dad running
around on the jungle gym but we give
each other the look yeah because you
know what's up we too are like the ones
fit enough not with the achy back or
like you know the messed up ankles like
yeah we can play with the kid you could
run across the field you could do
everything yeah and i don't mean to
sound judgmental at all i just want you
guys to see the standard in which i want
to live my life and i wanted to pick my
significant other to also be living
their life um
but you do you uh so like
yeah so that happened even before
getting pregnant once finding out we're
pregnant it was like super strict time
like i'm not missing out on a workout if
i can obviously sometimes you're just so
as like your body continues to change or
as you're [ __ ] yakking every week
because the first trimester is
the craziest i've ever felt i felt so
confused like my body felt so confused
what are some of the things that made it
feel so crazy i'm not a big food person
right like i don't eat a lot of meals
i'm like a grazer i like a lot of little
meals but like
scattered throughout the day
um
when i started i think maybe even like
you like little meals or you like snacks
little meals like just little bite-sized
eats
okay like last night when we had dinner
i probably had like a cup of everything
or maybe half a cup of everything and i
was like ooh i'm satisfied and then i
had dessert and then i chilled and then
like an hour or two later i had a little
bit more bite sizes you know
um so maybe your one meal
of the calories you're consuming i'm
consuming that you know with three small
meals or four small meals throughout
that that time i like three or four big
meals fine um
uh was i saying
that you're oh how i was feeling so yeah
i'm not a big eater like that but like
instantly it hit me i'm like i am
[ __ ] starving it felt like i was
locked away for weeks without food and
all i was consuming was just a little
bit of
like tasteless bread and water and
that's what i needed to eat so bad um
and i remember i was eating and i'm like
oh my god i want more and as i'm eating
i'm still getting hungry and i'm like
this is [ __ ] weird then i'm like i
don't know where [ __ ] i just have to
throw up remember that one time we were
eating pho oh yeah i was just eating it
was so good and i'm like oh my god i
have to throw up right now um and
someone was using the women's bathroom
so i walked into the men's bathroom
someone's in the stall i'm like yo dude
i'm pregnant i have to throw up and i
just threw up in the [ __ ] sink but
i'm like i'm not about to throw up
while people are eating that would have
been the worst but
yeah the dude was cool he was like in
the stall he didn't we didn't see each
other he was like totally understand i
get it do you i'm like thanks dude did
you ever look up like what is it about
being the first trimester that makes
chicks throw up man i forgot but i think
it's just
excuse me um i think it's just a lot of
hormones happening like you get tension
headaches um the only things that would
help me with these headaches because
just my hormones are uh running rampant
yeah they're just like creating life
yeah yeah um the only thing that would
help with these tension headaches was
actually exercising so exercising became
i became such a like so dependent on it
because it was the only thing that was
normalizing or stabilizing how much
hormones and everything yeah yeah i
literally felt like i had this parasite
like [ __ ] taking away everything for
me that sounds horrible because it's my
[ __ ] monkey dude but
it felt that way was that intense yeah i
just felt like something had invaded my
body and my body was just freaking the
[ __ ] out wow then my my temperature like
i'm i run cold like i'm a cold ass
person
uh and i remember we were eating at a
restaurant that i think they just had
either minor ac or they just
that had no ac but it was in the summer
in l.a it was still fresh it shouldn't
have made me feel this way but we had to
walk out because
i was so
hot i just couldn't finish my meal i was
so uncomfortable i was like i'm about to
[ __ ] pass out this is my body
temperature is way too hot right now so
that would happen
um i was absolutely exhausted because i
wasn't consuming any caffeine yeah so i
was still working too tired yeah working
we were this is when we were shooting
our long hours of jk news where we were
showing up at nine and wrapping up at
midnight
we were shooting those 40 episode days
and like on camera i was knocking out
like people are talking and it's a
serious topic and i'm nodding off
and um i was like well [ __ ]
sorry like
i'm on camera
but i'm not like i just didn't feel like
i wanted to consume caffeine because
um my my my gynecologist
uh was telling me like um he says yes
you can consume a cup of coffee safely
for sure you can have a cup of coffee
you can have
uh a little bit of wine
um but he says you know you also have to
remember that that a lot of other things
that we may be consuming thoughtlessly
may also have caffeine in it for example
chocolate yeah you know so like i just
said you know what i'm going to play it
super extra safe i'm going to be on the
extreme side
um i'm not going to touch any of that so
i stayed away from all of that but
that's why i was like nodding off all
the time
um another thing that happened was as
your stomach gets bigger you just can't
do anything you can't really put on
clothes i mean you can but it's just
hard
yeah um i lived in the same like three
pieces of outfit the whole time and i'm
not even complaining because they're
comfy
yeah because it was just easy and
thoughtless and like uh at least for me
the way i viewed pregnancy like i'm not
trying to be all stylish i'm just trying
to be comfortable you know like my body
was achy yeah it'll be over with in the
nine months yeah [ __ ] it you know like
um my my
my joints were hurting and achy and
um i couldn't even put on my shoes
anymore i remember we had a i had a
shoot where i wore this really nice
dress and i wanted to wear high heels
and you had to put on the high heels for
me because i just couldn't because the
high heel um
like the
the clip was on the side by my ankle
yeah and um i couldn't put my leg up
because my stomach was in the way and
like you had to put on my shoes
uh sleeping was really tough because
you're so exhausted but then at night i
i just couldn't go to sleep
i'm like what do you want for me bought
it what uh how come you can't go to
sleep like you feel i was just wide
awake i don't know where i just had this
[ __ ] message i felt tired i was
exhausted i was so exhausted and i'm
like please i want to go to sleep and i
just couldn't go to sleep that's crazy
um
and then you can't lay on your back
because like the bigger you get and the
further into the pregnancy um
you um
um it's uncomfortable you can't lay on
your back because now you just have
so you gotta sleep on the side 50 pounds
crushing you huh you have to sleep on
the side you're a constant side sleeper
which is fine because i was a side
sleeper but
man getting out of bed i'm like
rolling out of bed and i'm a big chick
you know i'm 5 11.
um
so i sh and i trained i should have been
capable but i'm still kind of waddling
around still
um
what else like your body changes like
the biggest change i saw was in my
nipples like they got really really dark
and then the plus side is i had the best
skin i've ever had my hair was so
beautiful and like shiny and it had this
like beautiful glow
and like my nails were just the
strongest they had ever been i think
maybe this was the first time i was
actually like
intentionally like
giving myself all the appropriate things
i probably was lacking prior to you know
oh like all the prenatal vitamins yeah
cause it they just jam pack it with a
bunch of good stuff in there good stuff
yeah
um
what else everyone's so sweet with
pregnant women
i loved it it was everyone was so kind
um if i was standing up men and women
older men older women grandma's grandpas
would move out and they're like here you
sit i'm like
thank you i'm so thank you but everyone
was so sweet with a pregnant woman if
i'm like trying to carry something you
see people rushing to just help
um and it was really heartwarming to see
like the community be like okay she's
she has life so it was really it was
really cool that's really cool um
driving became kind of scary for me like
i didn't want to drive because i just i
felt like i was putting myself in harm's
way
like especially behind your back
yeah like i just didn't want to drive
because i'm like what if i get in an
accident now an airbag or like there's
just very little room between my belly
and
the steering wheel so that i didn't want
to do i did double core rest
and then i got a brace jiu jitsu moves
yeah
um what about you during this phase for
me you're just living life is normal uh
the first trimester yeah i think the
biggest difference i noticed in myself
um since i don't go through any
bodily changes
it's more of like um
the dad radar
which i never
really had before because you know it's
usually like
um you kind of have like your spidey
senses out just for yourself you know
you're like oh it's that whatever what's
that
but i remember going into
um we went to vegas for something and
we're walking through the bellagio
and all of a sudden i could like i'm
like
that second-hand smoke what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] everyone stop [ __ ] smoking you
know and it's all like when you're in
vegas that's funny i know and i'd walk
in front of you and i'm like purposely
going like this i don't like because we
had to walk we're so exaggerating i know
because we had to walk through there to
go somewhere you know so i'm like okay i
can't let ma bear bring that breathe
this air
you know that kind of thing or even like
if we're um
if we're like walking around in downtown
like i'm like just like looking out
extra
that i never really
was like that a tentative before yeah
you were great you were always so
worried about how i felt if i needed
anything like you were very much
um
you were very much involved in the
pregnancy the entire way which was
really red yeah i was trying to like
make sure like oh cool like she's
running late for something maybe i could
go downstairs and grab a smoothie yeah
because i like i wanted to stick to like
giving the little monkey dude all the
best stuff you know yeah but then you
just can't move as fast as
you usually do or you're just stuck
throwing up or something you know so
we're still trying to like just whatever
plan and i think that's the biggest
thing
a lot of people i think when it comes to
having a baby first of all they don't
plan for it so it is something that just
comes in and it's a curveball and shakes
their whole life up and when you don't
plan for something i don't think you can
ever put your best foot forward i get
where that comes from too like our
parents didn't plan we just they just
didn't have time to plan so how did how
does anyone teach you i know i had a
plan so i think that's like the biggest
thing for most people like you need to
have a plan you know you need to have a
plan for everything yeah like if someone
comes
and i hear some
glass shatter i know where our guns are
located i know exactly what we're gonna
do i know you know like there's a plan
yeah versus glass shattering and now
you're trying to devise a plan
yeah that's tough you know you want to
have you don't want to you don't want to
brainstorm when it's an emergency you
want to execute when it's an emergency
yeah and so i think for us
we had a plan we know the type of
fitness we wanted to be in we didn't
know how the kind of happy state we
wanted to be in
because i remember remember like even
our hikes sorry all of our hikes really
started um
even before we had him because we were
just thinking it might be a good idea to
just get out and get some open mountain
fresh air every week you know just like
whatever you're breathing they're
breathing
this podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy i absolutely love every
time i get to talk about better help
whether that's here on our podcast or
whenever i do any ig
questions that you guys submit to me
because they are such a great service
better help is an online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist and i love
it because a lot of us you know might
live in areas where we can't have or we
don't have access to a lot of these
licensed therapists um so the fact that
you can go online from the comfort of
your own home um do it over the phone or
if you don't want you know your face to
be shown or you know you feel a type of
way about you know seeing someone face
to face you have a lot of options and
i'm a huge fan of options so better help
right now
is focusing this month on online therapy
and they want to remind you to take care
of your most important relationship and
that's the one that you're going to have
with yourself so we all know how
important relationships are right like
as a species
this is what we're created for we're
social creatures and how many of us go
above and beyond for the people that we
love
a lot of us right but how many of us go
above and beyond to love ourselves
not too many and you know for me
personally i've noticed in the past from
my past behavior that i would go above
and beyond for people um
and and i feel like i was doing that
because i was so scared to look at
myself and see whatever problems or
struggles that i was dealing with and it
wasn't until i started you know looking
into that and and really focusing on
that and fixing that that my
relationship with myself got better and
that's what i love about betterhelp that
again going back with the options you
can do it from the comfort of your own
home your own schedule you set the pace
you set the tone you set the you know
the boundaries and how you want to go
about it um so for everyone listening
right now
whether you're struggling with something
or not you know if you just need to talk
to someone or work some things out
better help is for you so because you're
listening to this podcast and it was
sponsored by better help
um you're going to receive 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com
get close that's b e t t e r h e l p
dot com
slash get close please please please
take us up on this offer
you really have nothing to lose and
literally everything to gain
so even that like let's get some
mountain fresh air and then you find out
they're breathing all their [ __ ]
amniotic fluids that includes all their
piss and they're eating it and [ __ ]
it out then eating it and [ __ ] it
out yeah like we could get some air
good nutrition let's try to sleep try to
be in a happy place so you got the good
hormones yeah you know going in there so
i think just planning for all of that um
and sticking to it doing whatever we can
to stick to it was so important yeah i
love that you knew that
um there were so many big changes
happening and you were just so
adaptive and you didn't question me
and you uh it felt like you really
trusted all the decisions that i was
making so i felt really supported that
was one thing i think i really learned
from my mom
my mom told me when she had me she
didn't feel support at all
and that's that's one part i felt so sad
for her
because one they're from that generation
where yeah mom does everything dad's
work person right
and my mom
um
she was pregnant and
my dad was trying to get his restaurant
going at the time
so it was like a lunch and dinner type
restaurant so my dad's gone from like 11
till 11 pretty much
and my mom was just kind of at home
newly immigrated to america
no friends
no no co-workers
not even a routine it's not like oh
she's gonna go to like yoga at three you
know and then like no support group none
of that stuff
and so my mom was just doing her own
[ __ ] she was just like well what do i
need to do to make sure like little bart
is healthy so she's just making her own
eggs going on her own little walks in
the park it was a very individual thing
and when my mom used to tell me that as
a kid i'm like man that sucks yeah so i
always wanted to make sure that
um for you you felt supported you know
yeah um
that's all i could think of in terms of
the prep oh another thing was um
and and i think everyone naturally
starts doing this but like within the
last month when like the baby's right
around the corner like getting your
house set up
um what i liked is that we had like so
at that time we lived in a two-story
nursery
yeah well
i see a lot of new parents do this and i
think it's so cute because we did this
too yeah but you're so excited to have
this baby and you're so excited to start
this new chapter in your life that
you're like stressing over the nursery
and doing all that stuff
um
and we didn't use ours
like for the first nine months
right or the first year actually
um so if you feel this pressure of like
setting up the nursery and this nurture
has to be done and blah blah blah blah
no just have a bassinet next to your bed
depending on how what kind of sleeping
style you want your feet yeah we because
we uh we had a bassinet for maybe the
first six months yeah and then a crib
because you need to because you need to
like
be there right
and then when we started sleep training
them we had the crib in the room yeah we
actually moved the crib out of the
nursery
into our room all right
so it wasn't until nine months
when we're like okay was it nine months
i feel like it was a year maybe it was
number i think it was nine months we
moved it back in
and it was the hardest week of our lives
where we can hear on the baby monitors
yeah we're sleep training we can hear
them crying yeah
we want to go there yeah we're not there
yet but then uh we
we just read that like the self-soothing
needs to happen like that's the
foundation for them self-soothing later
on
i'm like oh we got to go with it
and then we finally started using that
nursery yeah so yeah we didn't use it
until
um nine months to a year in so if you
feel this pressure of getting this
nursery ready don't sweat it i say like
find a spot in your house where you're
gonna want to spend the most time for me
it was the living room
and make that area uh [ __ ] what the
decor looks like [ __ ] having it
instagram ready [ __ ] all of that let's
stick to real life
and um
like we had i had two changing stations
one upstairs because that's the other
part where we lived our life yeah and
then one downstairs where it was the
majority where i spent my time was
because we have like an open concept
living room where you have the kitchen
dining room
um and living room it's all in just one
space so i had a changing table there
there with like the diaper trash can
i had extra clothes down there because
just having to go from room to room was
like if the baby's crying it's just like
it was just going to be a [ __ ] show so
everything i had
in my bedroom to take care of taika i
also kept the exact same stuff
downstairs so baby wipes extra clothes
toys
um
ointments creams
[ __ ] everything we could think of was
like double of everything so that helped
a lot because once
the baby came it was like
the house is no longer yours yeah like
that's it like
i i i was fortunate enough or we were
fortunate enough that we picked a really
cool
um hospital to deliver at
where the first 48 if not 72 hours they
taught me so much about like the
formulas that like i can look into if
you know because not every single woman
is going to be able to breastfeed like
the percentage of that is actually
really high and it's very normal so the
fact that you can't breastfeed doesn't
make you less of a mother or it doesn't
give your kids um
less uh
nutrients like taika is partially
formula and then taika is also partially
breastfed so i didn't feel guilty about
going to formula because i'm just like
my body just didn't produce that anymore
you know i was i was back on the working
i was back working and that if you don't
um
if you don't continue the supply then it
does go away so stuff like that um but i
never felt like guilty for it i didn't
feel bad because i just knew that
that's just what it is
um
yeah baby comes
the sleep is [ __ ] one thing that
helped me at least i don't know if it
helped you was keeping a journal of
feeding like just keeping a journal of
like 9 a.m wakes up
you know 11 a.m uh eat
11 30 diaper change like we can't
remember that journal we
wrote literally about all of that
for the first month we we wrote it all
down any movement that this child made
eating diaper change um waking up
sleeping naps all of that we documented
it yeah because the pediatrician wanted
to know too to make sure that we're
doing a good job yeah uh and we started
picking up patterns off that so we
started going oh okay so taika literally
wants to eat
every three hours
like every three hours on the dot i
already knew what to expect so it became
easier on myself
to be able to predict the behavior and
just start setting up my daily routines
that way because i'm like okay i know at
this hour this is going to happen
then this is gonna happen i'm gonna burp
bum and then after that um
you know i'm gonna have to
change him or whatever um i made it also
a point to take him outside because i
think he had a little bit of jaundice
like when they're a little bit yellow
yeah what is jaundice um i don't know
specifically i can't remember off the
top of my head but you have
yeah they do have like a maybe a vitamin
deficiency or something and that's also
very normal
and yeah they do have like a yellow skin
tone yeah so the more you have them
exposed to natural vitamin d that helps
with that my favorite thing was uh i
would come home from work
and then you your mom and taco would be
at that little park next to the house
like waiting for me yeah and i would
just see him like you know he's like
kind of wobbly but he's like holding on
to the bench yeah and it just made me
feel so cute that i had such a like a
cuny warm welcome coming home from work
every day yeah it was cool cause you
turned the corner and then you see us
yeah
um
another thing i didn't know what
happened
what would happen is we so i had a very
normal pregnancy or delivery pregnancy
all of that everything was very
um to the books
like nothing really um no real outliers
one of the things that happened when we
had taika was when he was in the womb he
would favor one side remember his neck
was tweaked oh yeah so he would only
look to the left he had better mobility
on one side yeah i forgot what the side
is i'm just gonna pick a side for now
yeah he couldn't turn the other way so
we had to take him to uh pt
and like he would get pt done like a
couple times a week and that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] expensive dude
but yeah he would teach us i think for
the first month we did it and he would
teach us the pt would teach us a bunch
of different um
neck exercises to help him because the
fear came that if we didn't do that then
he would need to have neck surgery oh
yeah
so i remember this poor little buddy man
new baby
and like um
having him feel any sort of pain i'm
like oh my god i can't have
and i would want to cry when i would see
this and i felt like a little guilty i'm
like how can i load this for my baby but
i'm like [ __ ] shut up you didn't have
any [ __ ]
how are you gonna control how the [ __ ]
he's sleeping in your womb even even the
first night felt like that the first
night he came out and then that was uh
pretty much like your recovery face
and you know they keep
keep taking them out to get his shots
and he probably got i don't know [ __ ]
eight of them or something
so i'm always going out to
because you know monitoring yeah because
there's always like the fear of like the
baby getting switched even though
they're double-tagged but getting
switched getting the wrong baby or
something like that you know yeah and so
like i'm always going out with them and
then they're like oh
do you want these shots i'm like yeah
just whatever the pediatrician
recommends i want all of it
and then every time you get a shot it's
in the leg or over here and i'm like
just this little little little little
thing there's no wrinkles he's so brand
new and he's just the needle goes down
he's just he's just crying i'm like oh
this guy's even know why he's crying
even this guy didn't know what's going
on
i feel so bad and then even now when
he's like three or four we take him to
the pediatrician he has to get updated
on certain shots
um we talked to him like he's always am
i gonna get shots we're gonna get shots
i'm gonna have to lie to this guy i
don't and i'm like [ __ ] i probably
should lie but i don't i'm like yeah
dude you have to i know we go and he
gets shots and then and even his leg
right now is still tiny you know and he
sees a big old needle go inside and he
cries i'm like oh and it's so funny i
judge and i don't mean to i love the
worker the health care workers but uh
when they're poking like the first time
they had to draw blood from his little
from his little um the bottom of his
foot yeah and i was judging her in my
head going don't you have kids how can
you make this happen you witch
how do you get pleasure out of like
hurting this poor new baby how do you
get a plan i know and i'm sure she
[ __ ] hates it too
yeah i'm just dogging her going like you
[ __ ] animal
no but i mean hey
they're doing it to keep our babies
alive yeah so i understand it but just
the emotional
mama bear side is just going like
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah um
yeah sleeping was a [ __ ] show it was so
bad
and um
i think the thing that helped me when i
because man it's [ __ ] hard on women
dude like especially if you're
breastfeeding you're the only one
and this child only wants to be with you
and most men
aren't the nurturing type so they're
they're kind of all awkward with a baby
or whatever which i'm like fine be
awkward but you're going to do it until
you're not awkward it feels [ __ ] good
that's the only way to learn
[ __ ] i don't even know if we're
built that way though i don't give a
[ __ ] you better [ __ ] learn
anatomically we're not built to be soft
but one thing because there were nights
where it was just so rough you're like
so exhausted and you're tired and you're
still recovering and like
mentally you just feel so weak and alone
you really do feel alone because
unless you have someone that you're
close to that you absolutely love and
respect going through the exact same
thing as you as the exact same time
you literally feel alone
but what helped me when i was feeling
alone or frustrated or fed up or tired
um or just sad
like you were with me every step of the
way i woke up with you every night yeah
yeah and
and it was i was getting [ __ ] wrecked
and it was so comforting because i like
like it got to the point where you would
get up with me and i just felt so good
because i'm like
i'm not alone at like 3 21 in the
morning you know yeah um and i see you
and your heads off your hair's all
[ __ ] up and your clothes are all
jacked up because you could tell you
didn't have like a good night's rest
either
but you're there with me and it felt so
nice um i think there's sometimes where
i'm up with you
and i'm like all right i'm up with you
and okay cool i'm like
all right
dude can i go back sleeping like stay up
[ __ ] i didn't feel that no you
didn't maybe you think of it as a joke
in your head but you never did that
really because i would have felt really
[ __ ] up i would have felt like you're
just doing it you know my sensitive ass
i would have felt like
i would have felt like damn he's not
being my partner he's just like i don't
know i i would have flipped it in some
sick ways i also [ __ ] hate the
feeling
of um
not being in control too
i hate that feeling oh what do you mean
so if i wake up right and i'm groggy and
then there's another voice that's like
go back to sleep i hate like oh so
you're gonna be a [ __ ] little [ __ ]
you can't [ __ ] just stay up after two
hours you know yeah so it makes me go
what the [ __ ] man [ __ ] you groggy ass
voice i'm [ __ ] up i'm up now you know
yeah but then after like a week you're
like [ __ ] i do want to go what's that
groggy voice you want me to do what now
okay you win yeah no but it felt really
good like i knew you couldn't do
anything but the fact that i was like
dang we are going through this together
and the
the thought that
knowing you can't even do anything to
still get your ass up i'm like you know
you can't help yeah but you didn't use
as as an excuse to like not help yeah
every time like clockwork baby cries we
both were both up and it got to the
point where i'm like oh my god i love
you so much and i was like baby just go
back to sleep
so i mean the waking up was good because
we're together but then me going like
i'm not gonna make you go through this
if you don't have to and then you know
and then just letting you go back to
sleep but
um for any new dads or anyone planning
any meals planning on having or partners
don't put it all on the chick even
though you feel like
well i can't do anything anyway it's
like the emotional part is the biggest
thing that we need yeah if i wasn't good
at taking naps already
i got real good
because you know like you get wrecked
you're waking up three times a night i
think we'd wake up once at like 11 and
then once i like won once at three and
then you're up now like at five or six
your regular time you know
and i'd get so [ __ ] wrecked and i
would be like i would wake up as if
i did i pulled the all-nighter
and then i would
you know that's when we created the
bartlett brigade pre-workout because
another pre-workout at that time was
good enough so i was like but i still
got goals you know so go crush the
workout go crush work
and the minute there's any downtime i'm
like okay people are talking hey
uh when's the next time we're gonna
shoot like oh in 30 minutes
perfect i would just [ __ ] find a
corner and just go and close my eyes
like as much as i could
to try to like you know when your
battery your phone battery is on red
yeah it's like the last it's like
it's like but you still need it for the
rest of the day any second you're just
you know are you are doing that charger
even if it's like 30 seconds or 30
seconds you know the phone will last if
you just keep doing it yeah so there's
times where i'm like i might be taking
like four five ten minute naps
just randomly you know i'm like i get to
like a location early turn the ac on
just lay here for like 10 minutes just
whatever i can to [ __ ]
stay up yeah so that i can continue
being supportive
um
no that was great you never complained
you never made it
i don't know i don't know why you would
but i never felt bad for any of that
um you were just such a dope partner the
whole way through
at what point did you feel like a dad
because for me as soon as i found out i
was pregnant it was like instant mom
mode
yeah same really that's not saying i got
my my dad's body senses yeah no like the
men i was like oh oh oh cool i'm gonna
be a dad i just felt extra responsible
yeah you know like because like i felt
like i gave like i aged 20 years
because i was thinking as a maturity or
yeah like i felt like i was thinking
like an older wiser person now because
it's not about me
no i never felt that because i felt like
um
i'm a pretty good planner
you know so even like as we were talking
to
have kids and stuff
like i would slowly like decrease my
spending i would like
look at our finances and go okay this is
the finances for two people
um are we doing it in a way that can
cover three or more
you know so i've already like that's
that's my mindset already
you know so i kind of slowly
i don't like straight up like 90 degree
turns and [ __ ] i like okay cool like if
that's gonna happen in six months
instead of going hardcore over there
let's just slowly kind of just bring in
the gauges yeah you know so that's
always like okay cool let's get rid of
the porsche
you know like just like slow like little
slow transitions
to get to
where we need it to be yeah um so i've
already been the dad
before we even started conceiving or
trying to conceive and then we conceived
that's when like that biological part
like i think that's when that part
kicked in where like all of a sudden i
had like a third nostril
i had a third nostril and like an eye on
the back of my head and i'm like
like what what's what's that like what
are those bad guys like what the [ __ ]
are those fools like what is that is
that [ __ ] motorcycle why is there all
this pollution over here like i would
just start sensing yeah extra [ __ ] you
know i'm so proud of myself for picking
you why because you're awesome you
promised yeah even if you were like a
shitty husband not that you ever worked
that's awesome
like uh you're such a great partner like
such a great dad oh nice cutie yeah but
i'm like yeah [ __ ] you did that no it
had nothing to do with that let's try my
best um no and it's awesome because i'll
hear stories from
you know other women
that
don't
have the same experience as me and
unfortunately their partner isn't as um
[Music]
is it isn't what they wanted them to be
you know and i'm like oh [ __ ] that's
rough i think i had really good role
models
like my parents i don't think
they were really good to each other
which is why they got divorced
but i think in terms of trying their
best
to be the best parent
i don't know if i've ever seen any other
um
parent try so hard like the amount of
sacrifice
you know we're like
um
like my dad was dating someone
and
my dog tyson was like barking all night
she went in the backyard and was like
whacking him with the stick and i caught
her
and then i'm like yo what the [ __ ] i'm
like no you don't discipline my dog you
don't hurt my dog like that i told my
dad
and she got kicked out the next day good
you know [ __ ] like i don't know if uh
a lot of
people would do that no they wouldn't
yeah my dad's like no this is my son is
my son's dog they still saw each other
but she was like my dad was like that
kind of behavior can't be had at this
house so we would still go to like
dinners and stuff and they're still like
she'll still come and wherever she was
dave would still like do that kind of
stuff but she didn't stay there anymore
and like um when i first got kicked out
of high school in cerritos and i moved
over to the san gabriel valley my dad
works night shift you know so he get he
leaves for work at 5 00 pm
he gets off work at two
comes home at three
and when i got kicked out of school
my dad was like
he might need a change of scenery i want
him to live with me
i go live with him
and i go who's gonna take me to school
you don't you come home at three and he
goes i will
and just like that like
[ __ ] every day
goes to sleep at three wakes up at six
to take me to school at seven
and then comes home
uh and then finishes the rest of his
sleep until 12. like no question asks
wow just does it
uh junior senior year wow you know like
like when i see like an example like
that i'm like man that's discipline
that's
commitment you know and even uh my dad
found out um i was smoking in junior
high
and my dad's been smoking since he was
i think eight oh my god yeah like he's
been smoking since he was eight you know
yeah i mean my grad european communist
china is crazy it's like
if there was a fifth world he grew up in
a [ __ ] fifth world country you know
and so
at that time he has like seven eight
brothers and sisters so everyone is just
living in misery so whatever you can do
to
pass the misery
that's what you do right so like imagine
like playing in a dirt puddle it's
raining you have one bowl of rice to
share amongst five people if the older
brother gets a hold of a cigarette he
takes a hit oh man you look horrible you
take a hit everyone it just gets passed
down so everyone gets a head change you
know like oh cool everyone feels just
good about themselves for just a little
bit you know
so it's not like he was trying to be
cool it was just everyone's in pain and
cold and wet and muddy and like
yeah he's like i feel bad too and the
big brother that's 16 told the brother
that's 12 the hit take a tip take a hit
the 12 year old told the eight-year-old
to take a hit so they all just take a
hit
and so he's been smoking for like 40
something years he found out i was
smoking when i was 12 to be cool and uh
he's like let's quit together and we
quit together and he just quit cold
turkey damn
so i think i had really um
really good role models and even my mom
you know like in the other podcast i was
talking about how it sucked growing up
because all my friends had their own
rooms i had to share a room with my mom
and the rest of the three rooms in the
house were rented out but seeing like
what you need to do to make finances to
make mortgage and going with my mom and
we know there's no craigslist or offer
up or anything we're we're going to the
supermarket
to multiple
chinese supermarkets to staple papers up
you know help my mom with ads
like at that time like i knew what my
mom would write in chinese and my
chinese wasn't even that good but i
would know how to copy it and make like
10 copies
for my mom and write all that in chinese
and just kind of like learning the
discipline and going through all of that
helped me understand what it took to
be a good parent
and so like when it came time
i was like i thought i was like i'm
pretty ready for this you know my
self-sacrifice
living for someone other than yourself
i'm i'm ready for it yeah yeah that
that's that's parenting in a nutshell
you know like
even the simple things like
going to the movies like that just
doesn't happen anymore because you have
a baby or you have a child you know that
just doesn't comprehend sitting there
for an hour two hours
in this dark room
having to focus on these images on the
screen like
um your life
doesn't stop but it definitely takes a
different turn
um
like the friends you hang out with like
you might not even be able to hang out
with your same circle of friends because
they're just not used to screaming baby
or they want to go and bar hop or they
want to like just they have different
activities and there's nothing wrong
with that but it's just now your life's
kind of take a turn and
and like things start changing
um
not in a good or in a bad way but they
just change i do remember the one tough
part socially now that you brought that
up was when um
taika first came out in like the first
six months and in our friends circle
we're in that phase of life right but
everyone else
like joe david all the social people are
still in like uh whether or not they're
in single mode
yeah they're single mode right i mean
yeah they have significant others but on
their taxes they're single yeah so when
they go like you know going to our
favorite place to eat after jake
anderson goomba you know how much i
[ __ ] loved it and everyone's talking
and just yeah my time
so being being yeah having to say no
all the time
not hanging out over there like on the
weekend oh everyone's gonna go shooting
or something but then because i know i
work monday through friday
so
saturdays and sundays i do want to spend
more time with you and taika saying no
to all those things like
a lot of the social stuff
is uh
is kind of tough it's hard especially if
it becomes obviously when you go like
when you come from a um
a perspective man the [ __ ] up you wanted
you wanted the [ __ ] kid yes of course
you know like you step up you're like
yup man the [ __ ] up oh people [ __ ]
shooting versus taking care of your son
for sure right but i think like uh those
are some of the things that it's hard to
see
coming up like foregoing some of your
favorite things and just the social
bonds and you definitely over time over
the the two three years where like
me and joe might have been like this or
me and david might have been like this
super tight but through lifestyle you
you do see it being a part right because
people and that's that's normal and it's
normal yeah people will live their own
life like if you were the go-to guy to
go snowboarding all the time but now you
said no ten times
there might be a different guy you know
or or you were the guy that was going to
get [ __ ] media tacos with every
single tuesday but now you say no 20
times there's gonna you know it's just
normal it's life it's uh
um but there's still like a nostalgic
part you're like oh man i missed when it
was just like us like this yeah the cool
thing with that though if
if you can remind yourself that people
will come back around
like if they're your true homies yeah
they're not even like that
um but like life brings you back
right so like we know david we know joe
they both want to have kids at some
point we know that they're gonna come
right back around and they're gonna jump
in on this [ __ ] parent train
and we know that we're gonna not be able
to all go snowboarding together but
guess what now because we all have
families we're all gonna go to the snow
together we're gonna get a cabin things
are a little bit slower but now you guys
get one hour of snowboarding time you
know what i mean like life will
life will bring you back where it needs
to bring you back
so like when [ __ ] like that was
happening i didn't really think about it
too much because i'm just like this
isn't forever
like i know how quickly kids grow up so
i never felt like i was gonna miss out
on on anything the only thing though
that i felt like
is important to really focus on and and
and hold on to as [ __ ] hard as you
can is balance
um because as a woman and as a mother
a lot of that responsibility is put on
us in the beginning because it has to
right we're the nurturers where our
bodies literally giving them life like
even our mindset like we feel guilty
when we're away from our kids we hear
another kid scream and our body tells us
to start producing milk so then we
started screening milk out of our
nipples and it's not even our baby
crying like just biologically we're
supposed to be with our kid but what
happens is
and um there's nothing wrong if you're
okay with this but you kind of start to
lose you start losing a sense of self
like the old you is kind of dead now and
you have to say goodbye to that but
there's still remnants of who you are at
the core that's still there and i should
and i and i think it's really important
to nurture that and give yourself that
balance and go out once in a while away
from your kids and trust your spouse and
hopefully you have a significant other
that you can trust that's one thing that
i love that i have with you is that i've
ne any time i've ever just had my me
time
even if it's for an hour or whatever or
even if it was for a weekend i never
felt like you needed my help
i felt like you're so involved from like
the very beginning to this point that
like
i can leave without any type of doubt
that this baby will be good so that was
really good well that's also to me like
i know how important that is for a human
being you know the balance part yeah
it's like yeah we all want to be good
mommies and daddies and we want to be
there all the time
but kind of like how i told you like um
when i am able to train in the morning
and for some reason whatever it is once
i get that
out of me i'm like level-headed i have
all that aggression out
i'm like operating from a state of
euphoria because i've got all my
serotonin and dopamine firing the right
way i make better decisions
by better dietary financial social all
kinds of better decisions just because i
train in the morning yeah even if i woke
up groggy yeah no but getting that out
yeah and so that's
my daily check
right and so i think people have to they
got daily checks for their balance
people will also need weekly checks for
the balance and monthly checks for the
bounce so even if you're like a olympian
volleyball player
if you don't play volleyball for a year
you probably lose that identity yeah you
know and that's important
so whatever however frequently you need
to do it maybe you used to play
volleyball every single day
um and that's important too maybe you
can't do that anymore no but if you
could do it once a week or maybe even
once a month or even once a quarter yeah
that's enough yeah to keep that part of
you alive yeah because like all the
things that you gain from being an
olympian volleyball player like let's
say your tenacity your discipline all
all those really good benefits if that
identity dies i think so do those traits
yeah for sure and and i know at the
beginning of this i'm like yo if you're
not willing to sacrifice then you're not
ready to be a parent and i feel like yes
i still stick to that obviously i'm
saying it but um
when it comes to yourself and like who
you are as a person
it's really important to to still keep
that person around
um
because like i said right like kids my
mom has always told me this and i ever
since she said these words it's it's
really stuck with me she said kids are
borrowed
like
like you and i we're gonna be together
until we die
right um i'm gonna be with myself until
i die but my kid our kids
they're gonna grow up and start their
own family they're gonna leave we're
gonna be empty nesters one day you know
so then at that point who are you left
with
yourself and if you don't know who the
[ __ ] you are then that's when a bunch of
weird [ __ ] starts happening you know so
this can't wait to see tycho's family
it's so [ __ ] cool i know oh like it's
gonna be so cuny to say monkey dudes
monkey dude i know
i hope i live to see that man i hope i
live to see that crazy
but um
yeah parenting is a lot of
self-sacrificing and a lot of
life-changing and a lot of um putting
your kids first before yourself but also
not neglecting yourself and that's still
a form of balance
especially i think if those
parts of yourself
are who your identity is and also drives
you to be a better person yeah so like
like trading yeah yeah yeah yeah even uh
like one thing that felt so good i
didn't know i was gonna feel this good
was the first
i think the first nine months to a year
i love shooting right like shooting does
so much for me
it's one it's something i learned in the
military so it's part of that identity
part of that like um that past time that
i really enjoy
two it um
helps me feel good as a protector
that i'm like because come with with
shooting comes like weapons handling
comes situational awareness
comes like fast hand eye coordination
comes very proper thing safety protocol
so like not just safety protocol in like
the gun aspect but like let's say
something as simple as like i could go
oh can i borrow that knife i take the
knife already spin it around in my hand
and i hand him the handle first just
like the concept and the the movement of
the process of safety protocol and
everything when i'm doing construction
like building this podcast the minute
taika comes i already unplug it and i
put the drill to the side no power tools
when he's around because i don't want
him to press something and something
happens i see him go back inside i plug
that back in now like just
that gun has so many parallels in the
rest of the way that i live
and so when i don't go shooting when
they're in the first nine months to a
year because i just don't have time
i can feel that side of me like die down
you know and i'm like oh this feels so
sad i'd like and i could find a like the
military part is kind of fading away the
protector part kind of fading away
and then just one day i think i was in
the garage in between training and sets
i'm like i'm just gonna weapons handle
and then there's that one video of me
like doing squats with like a holster
and stuff like that i just opened up the
safe and i'm just like dry firing which
is like no bullets practicing unloading
changing clips
and just that kind of reinvigorated the
protector
reinvigorated like oh cool if something
bad happens what is the plan at home how
do we evacuate is it the back is it the
front
um
and just all of that just clicked in so
even like i wasn't able to go shooting
but to be able to nurture the parts of
you that make you who you are in a
positive way i think is so important too
super cuny yeah you're such a cool
[ __ ] dad really yeah i love it i love
it um i don't know i just love the way
you think you know it's never like you i
never feel you go oh [ __ ] let me prep
it's always like you've been prepped
um
and you're just so you're so fair and
you're so respectful
and you're so willing to learn and you
know a lot
and the self-sacrifice
i mean just everything you're just such
a you're just like my favorite partner
ever oh thank you yeah and like
is so [ __ ] lucky to have you because
you're just so fun too
this is cuny big cuny guy all right well
on that note um before i start [ __ ]
crying my makeup away um
yeah thank you guys for constantly
asking these questions in the dms if if
we don't get to you guys in the comments
below definitely shoot us shoot us a dm
or just shoot me the dm because bart's
not checking that [ __ ] nah i i need my
own mental clarity i would love to talk
with everyone
it gets overwhelming for sure yeah like
we appreciate it we love it but if we
spent our whole day um if we spent
time answering every single dm we got we
would never have any time to do anything
else yeah which is still a blessing
right to be to to have people trust you
and and follow you and want to learn
from you so deeply um that they they
reach out to you is is a [ __ ]
blessing and i'm so grateful and i don't
take that for granted but um hopefully
we were able to
shed a lot more light in this one
episode um so that um
you know that question you guys can at
least go like okay cool i know where to
go i know there's a resource if there's
a friend that has those same questions
hey check out this podcast they kind of
go into detail stuff like that again if
there's anything that we uh we can
answer that we've gone through that you
guys want to know please hit us up about
it it's these are always so cool and we
kind of forget that we have this
knowledge sometimes so it's really cool
to go back and either reminisce forgot
we went through all that you know yeah
um so thank you guys so much
love you appreciate you and i hope
you're having a beautiful day and uh
we'll catch you next week bye
[Music]